[Music]
for him
um
[Music]
once I was
um
[Music]
[Laughter]
foreign
[Music]
I am
foreign
[Laughter]
down
here
[Music]
foreign
the three Muslims minus two plus Jad how
you doing today brother alhamdulillah
how are you
doing good my man all right so today
we're going to be discussing um brother
Ruslan and um as he mentions in the
video I'm friendly with him we've
discussed a few times he did a reaction
to sneako's conversion to Islam or
reversion as we say and I think he made
some interesting points and it was a
full thing but I saw the first few
minutes so I'm going to go over that and
then later we're gonna have a revert who
accepted Islam uh I think for quite some
time ago come on and share his story
inshallah
so with that being said let us begin
everyone's really loving the uh the new
countdown with brother
which uh
amazing recitation may Allah reward him
a very interesting point brother Kareem
112 people not 170 people and only 47
likes what the heck is going on come on
guys Step It Up Step It Up hit the like
button and Shout Allah subscribe and
share the stream with someone who will
benefit inshallah now with that being
said I think we should just jump into
the reaction what do you say bro
I'm down
right Bismillah and
let's begin
disclaimer one point is I'm going in
completely blind into this video so okay
uh so is great Point number two is I
know Remy from the three Muslims we've
been friendly uh over text message uh
we've sent voice notes back and forth
and Remy actually may be coming on the
channel uh he wanted to interview me I
wanted to talk to him getting
information from the source's mouth I
think there'd be some great grounds for
for disagreement cordial charitable
disagreement because I think if you're
going to disagree about us something as
Christianity versus Islam probably
should happen in person after a meal and
again so this is snico this is at the
hour and 15 minute time stamp and this
is his view on Christian and I think I
I'm gonna know where he's going with
this eventually we understand Jesus
peace people never died right so he just
got lifted and it was swapped out he
wasn't the one that was crucified or
anything like that so uh interesting he
says you know their position is is
basically Jesus we got lifted up like uh
Elijah in the Old Testament ironically
enough we cover covered a Muslim uh
scholar who takes the minority View and
I'll try to link that video that holds
that Jesus did actually get crucified
and did actually die and did actually
resurrect okay
let's pause that for a second I think
that was a that was quite the load there
so he's saying that
he
apparently a Muslim scholar says that
Jesus
did die and he was crucified and he was
resurrected as well
um I haven't heard of such an opinion
before he didn't name the scholar in the
video so I don't know who he's talking
about but I don't think that opinion
actually exists you might find you might
find a very very my minor opinion right
maybe one or two Scholars have this
opinion that Jesus was put on the cross
but did not die on there and the
reasoning is that a crucifixion is when
you actually put on the cross and you
die from it being put on the cross is
not crucifixion is when you're upon the
cross and you die as a result that's
some weird opinion the ahmadis which
they're not Muslim say the same thing
which maybe they actually believe in
you know what bro you know what makes so
much sense that he spoke to in Ahmadi
he didn't say that but think about it he
said that this scholar said that Jesus
was put on the cross and he died and he
was resurrected they actually believed
that Mirza Gula Muhammad is basically
Jesus all over again did you see he said
he was going to link it in the
description I doubt he did but really
yeah he said he was going to link in the
description this scholar he was talking
about uh brother so many links here
Roslyn bro you gotta kind of minimize
the amount of links you're using man yo
what is this man wait let me let me pull
it up again but yeah that's interesting
whenever they I mean nowadays you could
find any scholar saying anything
unfortunately anyone calls himself a
scholar wow that is a lot of links yeah
it doesn't look like he put it in there
I don't see it
maybe forgot to it's okay Ruslan you
have my number bro please send me the
links inshallah okay I think that's the
next reaction we're probably gonna do
but
yeah so
I don't think there's any Muslim scholar
that really says that but regardless I
mean I have nothing else to add to that
if you want to continue with the video
bro what do you think yeah let's
continue I mean like I was saying the
unfortunately nowadays you don't know
I could say I'm a scholar people would
take my word for it yeah so I mean
anyone could say they're a scholar and
uh
it's just
yeah I don't know it's just frustrating
because then it looks bad on Muslims
once a supposed scholar is saying
something that we obviously don't agree
with
yeah 100 and let me say quickly I love
Brothers I think he's a great guy this
is obviously just you know just kidding
we're just joking around there's no hate
against them no of course of course and
inshallah hopefully we can link soon as
he mentioned I don't think it's gonna
end up happening I think our schedules
are too conflicting but we'll see
inshallah so do you believe anything how
has your relationship with Jesus changed
from Christianity to Islam in the way
that you viewed Jesus peace be upon him
as a Christian versus now as a Muslim
it fixes all the the complaints I had
internally when I was going to church
when I was growing up uh personally
I didn't like the fact that and notice
respect to the Catholics watching I
didn't like the Holy Communion where you
go I don't know if you understand but
the priest has a bowl of crackers
literally and then he hands it to you
and he says this is the body of Christ
and then you take it and then you put it
and then you're symbolizing that you're
taking Jesus's sacrifice so essentially
it's I don't want to be disrespectful I
want to say this but essentially it
symbolized cannibalism
[Music]
it symbolized cannibalism and I can see
where him as a Catholic basically they
believe that
uh the priest is able to when he lifts
up I don't know if you ever see where
they lift up the um bread and cup but
basically at that moment when he prays
that that bread becomes the actual body
of Jesus and that cup becomes the actual
blood of Jesus uh I am more me Ray
Castro is really more in in more in the
uh Lutheran side of of this uh idea
where I don't believe is just a symbol
um because I believe that we're doing
this in the presence of God
and that um if it was just a symbol then
there wouldn't be any warnings in the
New Testament where Paul said hey some
of you have taken this and have actually
died you know
um and uh I'm a person that takes
scripture very uh seriously and
um so I believe that there's a real
presence in the act of taking communion
I don't think it's just a symbol
Catholics and Protestants yeah would
have some form of disagreements on
how literal does
the blood and the the sacrament the
blood and the um the body become right
uh I think all Christians would say it's
something is going on in the spiritual
sense Christ is Among Us trans
substantiation holy moly that is a
mountain trans I can't pronounce it
either that's why I didn't come with
them yes
so we would agree that there's something
that's happening that there's something
spiritual happening that that God is
definitely the presence of God is in the
sacrament the difference is
and I don't mean to make a character of
Catholic theology but the difference is
I don't know if Catholics would go as
far as to say you eat the bread you eat
the wine you drink the wine and then
they cut you open look at the DNA of
what that that item is did that
literally become flesh
and blood right again I'm not trying to
make a character of it but I don't I
don't know if they would go as that far
but it definitely seems like they go
more of the something is physically
changing of those elements they believe
okay well I think that I don't know I
don't know what Catholics believe I
think that might that might be a bit of
a caricature of it
that is crazy yeah there's a lot to
unpack here just with this whole topic
and some of the things that were
mentioned so firstly
um you know in in Greek mythology they
actually have something called
homophagia which it literally means
eating one's God or eating your God so
it's something that exists and there was
it's really interesting so inshallah
very soon I'm going to drop a podcast
with the New Testament scholar named Dr
Dennis McDonald and he authored a book
which is almost like an encyclopedia
that talks about
um when basically early Christians or
the gospel writers or new testament
writers took old stories of other people
and put it onto Jesus and it's called
literary Nemesis right because it's like
a meme basically the Bible Loki in a way
is a meme in some in some sense yeah
with no disrespect literally it's
literally nemesis
so
they have this idea of eating one's God
and if you read a play titled the bakai
by a man named euripides who lived like
hundreds of years before Jesus you see
he he basically depicts a god who's a
half man half God basically named
Dionysus who's always dual in nature
and he is a person who basically like
creates or makes wine for his Believers
to drink
uh and there was a reason he did that I
don't remember why in the play but you
could see there's already parallels
between this person Dionysus and the the
early Paul's christology of Jesus you
know eating the bread homophagia
drinking the wine just like dionyses
um he's dual in nature dynasties he's
just like Jesus is dual in nature he has
the human nature
so there's so many similarities and then
on top of that this is a side note
um when Luke writes and Acts of the
Apostles about how his his teacher Paul
who once was Saul met Jesus on the road
um the story is very similar that he was
persecuting the Believers in in Jesus or
in the play persecuting the Believers of
Dionysus and then the God himself Jesus
or Dionysus appears to the person and
says why are you persecuting me and
there is a very specific uh phrase which
is kicking against the goads which is
basically like you're wasting your time
this appears in the play hundreds of
years ago the same story with a very
similar character who is God and the Son
of God because they believe Zeus is
capital letter G God in in Greek
mythology
um
approaches this person who uses that
exact same phrasing
so it's it's almost as if they copied
the story and put it onto Jesus and
copied the idea of drinking the blood of
your God and or the wine and eating your
God from Greek mythology
that is just a crazy
idea to me even thinking about like
in a very like simple sense just logical
sense just thinking about that idea of
quote unquote eating your God like how
how could you want to do that like
partaking that I don't
I don't know it just sounds sounds crazy
to me yeah and see that's the thing I
mean with all due respect to Christians
I think they were given a framework that
they have to work within they didn't
choose it you know the whole idea of
meeting your God it's there it's there
you can't do anything about it you have
to make it work Jesus being the Son of
God and God and and being human at the
same time you they have to make it work
that's why there have been so many
iterations of how Jesus Is God and so
many workarounds that were deemed
heresies they had subordinationism
separationism modalism and then
eventually trinitarianism which stuck
now
there are so many different
understandings of how Jesus is god
um a lot of them were just kind of
thrown in the garbage um not to be
disrespectful but like the Christians
themselves threw it away yeah they
disregarded them they deemed them as
heresies but
um let's get back to it inshallah and
see what they they carry on with here
that those elements are changing and
they they literally believe it's the
actual body and blood of Jesus yeah and
they believe it in faith I do think we
should ask some well-studied Catholics
on the exact position absolutely because
I don't want again I don't want to
create a character but I do want to show
what the scriptures say which ironically
is enough such a telling Passage
and it and it literally captures exactly
what's Nico's saying
because he just doubles down on this
okay let's go to John 6 32. I tell you
the truth Moses didn't give you bread
from Heaven my father did and now he
offers you true the true bread from
Heaven the true bread of God is the one
who comes down from heaven and gives
life to the world sir they said give us
that bread every day Jesus replied I am
the bread of life whoever comes to me
will never be hungry again whoever
believes in me will never be thirsty but
you haven't believed in me though you
have seen me however
those the father has given me will come
to me and I will never reject him for I
have come down from heaven to do the
will of God who sent me not to do my own
will and this is the will of God that I
should not lose even one of all those he
has given me but that I should raise
them up on the last day for it is my
father's will that all those who see his
son and believe in him should have
eternal life I will raise them up on the
last day then the people began to murmur
in disagreement because he said I am the
bread that came down from heaven they
said isn't this Jesus the son of Joseph
we know his father and mother how can he
say I come down from heaven but Jesus
replied stop complaining about what I
said for no one can come to me unless
the father who sent me draws them to me
and at the last day I will raise them up
as it is written in the scriptures they
will be taught by God Almighty everyone
who listens to the father learns from
him who comes to me not that anyone has
ever seen a father only I who is sent
from God I tell you the truth anyone who
believed has eternal life yes I am the
bread of life so he's doubling down on
this bread of life but while she takes
it a step further your ancestors ate
Manna in the wilderness but they all
died anyone who eats bread from Heaven
however will live will never die
I am the bread that came down from
heaven anyone who eats this bread will
live forever in this bread which uh I
will offer so the world may live is my
flesh so Jesus repeatedly doubles down
on I am the bread I am the bread I am
the bread
let's pause there I want to get your
sound effects is so funny oh the side
effects
yeah let me see him click it like right
after he finishes reading it he just
clicks the buttons
it is funny I've been thinking about
adding um sound bites here as well I
just have never gone around to it but I
don't think I'd do anything super
dramatic maybe I give myself a round of
applause or something like that yeah
yeah exactly yeah but um so I think it's
interesting what he's saying here
because firstly we don't believe in the
Gospel of John obviously right we we
believe that it's probably the most
heretical out of the um the four gospels
in the New Testament uh and it's the
last one that was written the last one
to be
um collected as well so
obviously there's a lot of skepticism
even with these passages but let's
assume that Jesus actually said these
things a lot of it sounds very
metaphorical a lot of it is right
obviously it cannot be literal because
Jesus is saying eat eat my eat the bread
from Heaven and the bread from Heaven Is
My Flesh did the people start eating him
alive no so obviously it's not a literal
thing it's a uh it's something that is
metaphorical now can this metaphor even
this could this metaphor be understood
in a in a Islamic sense I would say
actually yes because if you think about
it does he could just be speaking about
you know eating this bread from Heaven
is uh fulfilling the Commandment that he
is bringing to the people and obeying
him and listening to him and when he
says I will resurrect them and so on and
so forth it doesn't necessarily mean
that he is the one who's doing it but
that um they will be resurrected you
know with him or because uh of following
him they'll be resurrected in a certain
State and so on and so forth like there
are many ways to interpret it that it
does not you know kind of beget
something that is literal or amophagia
like I mentioned before
yeah I agree I was thinking about I mean
everything he was saying like you said
it sounds like fairly metaphorical like
you like listen to my teachings type I
guess that's what that's what I was
trying to kind of getting from if you
listen to my teachings then you will
live forever
but like obviously like not physically
live forever but I think that's that's
at least what I got from it I wouldn't
take it literally
um because like you said if they were to
take it literally then they why didn't
they just start eating his flesh like
while he was alive in front of them yeah
100 and you know what's super
interesting about this
um there are other passages in the
Gospel of John specifically that what
allude to Jesus not being God that would
kind of point away from the uh
christology that Paul had and a lot of
Christians have today
which is that Jesus is God and so on and
so forth you know versus obviously I
think like John 17 3 where he says that
um
the only or the basically the fathers
are the only God
and um he is basically an apostle of God
like a messenger basically yeah right we
hear a lot in Islam Allah's Apostle it's
like a messenger
all right and if you look at New
Testament scholars in their works a lot
of them believe that Jesus was this
description I'm about to give obviously
he was Jewish and he was a Jewish
teacher he was a prophetic figure he was
you know a messiah or a type like
Messianic figure and he came to
reinstill the laws of Moses and the
people and actually make practicing the
law easier
so he took the law of Moses and God
commanded him to actually abrogate some
things to make it easier for the people
to practice this is what Dennis McDonald
believes about him this is what some
other scholars believe about him it
almost seems to be a consensus to be
honest from just general New Testament
scholarship
so this is very much in line with what
we believe as Muslims to begin with so I
think that's a very interesting point
and the whole thing about eating your
God and that stuff I I don't see it
anywhere else other than
the the like for example the Gospel of
John which was written later you know
Paul's christology and understanding of
Jesus and Greek mythology to be frank
which was very popular at the time so if
you look in the beginning of the video
and he would start not at the beginning
of the video beginning of when he starts
reading this
I mean I don't know if I was like
misunderstanding it
um but it looked like in the Bible
um or Jesus was saying
like I was sitting down not by my own
will I'm here just to deliver the
message of God yeah that's kind of
confusing to me like it sounds pretty
clear in that that he's saying like I'm
not God essentially like
he's referring to God as like another
deity so I'm
I'm a little bit confused as to how they
interpret that
as him being God like I don't know how
that how does that work yeah so what
they will say is that Jesus is a
different person from God
um with a different will but now I think
this is super problematic because you
have
to different people
with different Wills maybe even
different Minds with different bodies
and Essences you could say because Jesus
was physical and the father was never
physical yeah so you're describing two
separate beings but you're just calling
them two different persons right two
different persons would be like one body
personality disorder or something like
that you know two different
personalities two different
understandings two different sets of
memory right so yeah they're United in
essence or something like that but
they're different persons but the way
you describe them they're just different
beings all together so I think this is
the biggest problem with it and like I
said like with all due respect to
Christians they were given a framework
that they have to operate Within
and you just can't right it's kind of
like trying to insert Islam until uh
liberalism is trying to insert Islam
into a liberal Society it just it does
not work because the foundations of it
just they con they contradict each other
they don't make sense
so it's unfortunate but
yeah
oh and if you want to live forever you
have to eat my flesh okay then the
people began arguing with each other
about what he meant
how can this man give us his flesh to
eat what what does Nico just say yeah
cannibalism it sounds like cannibalism
right Jesus said Jesus uh doubles down
again verse 53 yet again right he says
uh I tell you the truth unless you eat
the Flesh of the son of man and drink
his blood you cannot have eternal life
within you but anyone who eats my flesh
and drinks my blood has eternal life and
I will raise that person at the last day
for my flesh is True Blood and my blood
is uh excuse me my flesh is True Food
and my blood is true drink anyone who
eats my flesh and drinks my blood
remains in me and I in him I live
because of the living father who set me
in the same way anyway honestly I think
this doesn't change anything he's just
like Jesus and apparently In this
passage he's just saying the same thing
over again exactly it's repeating him
the same exact words he actually doesn't
describe it and let's be let's be real
like if if
or someone asked me a question about
Islam like let's say I say you know we
believe the prophet Muhammad is a true
prophet and he's like okay
how like I thought you know he's not a
true Prophet didn't he do XYZ didn't he
believe XYZ and I'm like hear me listen
he's a true prophet
yeah yeah I was like didn't okay didn't
he you know fight in battles he's a true
Prophet it's like it doesn't get
anywhere there's no experience yeah
exactly like it's the same thing here
supporting evidence one who feeds on me
will live because of me I am the true
bread that came down from heaven anyone
who eats this bread will not die as your
ancestors did even though they ate the
Manna but will live forever obviously
that can't be literal because the people
died we would still have Paul and the
disciples walking around there'd be no
difference of opinion we'd know exactly
who is who and they can narrate it to us
not that we'd believe them if they claim
that but yeah they would have lived that
whole time
so obviously it's metaphorical he's
talking about the afterlife they'll live
forever in the Kingdom of Heaven and the
kingdom of God and yeah exactly
he said these things while he was
teaching in the synagogue many of his
disciples
many of his disciples so this isn't the
12 I think this is the 72 right because
Jesus had the three clothes the 72
extended okay
um
many of his disciples said this is very
hard to understand how can anyone accept
it
you know what this sounds like so let me
let me let me phrase this in the um
it within the the framework of literary
Nemesis or actually not sorry not
literary Nemesis but within historically
what was happening at the time so
people did not believe the same thing
about Jesus historically speaking Yeah
the ABIA Knights who didn't believe he
was God he had uh the you know Pauline
Christians who followed Paul who
believed he was God and the Son of God
and so on and so forth and you can even
read in Paul's writings that he's
actively debating with them he's
actively saying you guys are denying the
cross you're just deniers of the Cross
you know going back and forth with them
so it really seems to be the case that
whoever wrote John which by the way
Paul's letters and christology came
before even the first gospels written
this is the last gospel to be written
right so it's very likely that whoever
Paul um taught influenced this gospel
and this person is writing this in spite
of those who are rejecting Jesus
there are probably people who are going
to them saying this does this stuff
doesn't make sense so they invented a
story where people said the same thing
to Jesus this doesn't make sense and he
just repeats it again and again like
just quiet and listen
historically speaking that makes
probably the most sense rather than
Jesus as this amazing prophetic teacher
this inspirational person who changed
the hearts of people all he did all he
can do is repeat himself over and over
again I don't think that's a great
depiction of the great man that Jesus
peace and blessings
like there's a lot of contradiction just
overall I don't know doesn't make it
doesn't make a lot of sense to me but
yeah yeah I don't know I wonder what
everyone else thinks
um Luna says it's metaphorical but seems
to be manipulated as well that's the
thing I think like I mentioned it's a
framework that they have to make work so
I think they choose what's metaphorical
literal based on you know whatever they
have the ability to
it's a spiritual immortality that you
said I think that's what we were saying
we were agreeing with
yeah 100 but if that's the case then
it's not literally you know like why is
that
put into a little cracker at church or
put into a cup of wine
if it's metaphorical why you literally
physically drinking something if it's a
metaphor
you know what I mean yeah why is it
literal in one sense and then one step
later it becomes metaphorical
does that make sense
yeah
Allah
I get it
absolutely right Jesus was aware that
his disciples were complaining so he
said to them do this do the does this
offend you then what will you think if
you see the son of man Ascend to Heaven
Again the spirit alone gives eternal
life human effort accomplishes nothing
and the Very words I have spoken to you
are spirit and life but some of you do
not believe me
this is why I said uh versus the last
verse here this is why I said that
people can't come to me unless the
father gives them to me so here we have
Jesus doubling down on this claim and
there and they're probably feeling the
way snico feels absolutely right they're
probably feeling house Nico feels which
is like yo this sounds a lot like
cannibalism is it's kind of crazy right
John 16
. I have spoken verse 25 I've spoken
these matters in figures of speech but
as soon as I stop speaking figuratively
until you plainly all about the father
then you will ask in my name I'm not
saying I will ask the father on your
behalf for the father himself loves you
dearly okay it says it in red right
there yeah then Jesus said he's he spoke
these things figuratively right like the
people in the Bible are not less human
than we are today
you know what I mean yes the question is
is
um what are you gonna do
with what Christ requires of you yep you
know what I mean yep so like whether you
believe it literally becomes his
physical body and his actual blood you
know um and it's not figurative speech
um or not you know will you do this in
remembrance of him absolutely and shout
out to Gladys she she pointed out this
is a good take I think same concept if
we are cannibals then we also can climb
back into our mother's room and be born
again absolutely same concept and that
was another thing they struggled with
right right so these are
let's take a quick pause for a second
inshallah and I I actually I think it's
funny because it's like they're pointing
out their own contradictions within do
they believe it or not are they like it
doesn't sound like they they believe
that like the physical aspect of it
that's that's the thing that's the thing
but the issue is there's no practice of
people trying to crawl back in their
mother's room there's a physical
practice of drinking wine and eating
bread so why is this metaphor being
literally in physically done during
their their sessions at Mass
that literally says figures is like he's
speaking in figures of speech yeah yeah
exactly 100 so we're going to take a
brief pause um John I know you're gonna
have to go in about 10 minutes or so
um we have a surprise guest today like I
mentioned we have a brother who recently
accepted Islam and uh we're gonna bring
him on for a little bit and discuss the
story I think donshallah he could really
benefit the people in his story and a
reversion to Islam
my brother are you ready
all right I'm going to bring you on
here we go brother how you doing
how are you doing I'm very good very
good I was listening to the conversation
and I take it you had a Trinity
Christian guy you just hold on
foreign
yeah yeah it was a Christian friend
named roslan
oh very good no I was I was listening
with the Jesus discussion about like the
drinking the blood and eating and the
wine and that sort of stuff just
infuriates me I'm not gonna lie that's
exactly what pushed me away from
Christianity and towards Islam was
because you know you look at Christian
nations now pornography is completely
illegal the entire Financial system is
based on user rape and people were just
kind of like
circle jerk whether Jesus
I think
oh we lost him for a second
hey bro sorry we lost you for a second
your camera's off now
just can you hear me yeah we can hear
you we just can't see you
oh my
God it's okay I think he's gonna leave
and come back
then where is he what is Australia
I have no idea that's a good question
though yeah nice accent he has yeah how
long has he been Muslim
um I don't know his Instagram he posted
in the Masjid since April so
I think he's been Muslim for at least at
least two months Maybe
and show us
see if we can get him back on Let Me
Show online shall I'll bring him up when
uh yeah so his name is Lord bear I uh I
didn't want to say that just because you
know like Lord Allah is our Lord yeah
um so ask for his real name I don't know
if he's okay with me saying it so I
won't say it but uh we'll call them
we'll call him Baron sha Allah for now
that's fine yeah
um he plus a clown said God gave us
logic to understand existence but
Christianity wants to take that out the
only religion that goes well with the
mind is that goes with the Mind well is
Islam so
you know Jordan Peterson mentioned this
in the interview with um Mom and a job
oh you're back all right I'll talk about
this afternoon
no worries brother so yeah you were
saying
hey yeah I was just saying that's
exactly what pushed me away from
Christianity was that if you look at the
problems in the world especially in
Christian nations and I always like to
use the phrase you'll know them by their
fruits and if you look at the sin and
what used to be Christian nations or
your Empire Financial system is based on
usury
divorce rates are 60 the birth rates are
an all-time low and pornography is
completely legal and accessible to
children and yet there's no discussion
of how to stop that it's just
being the Trinity was Jesus God even
though he prayed to God and just all
this garbage it just seems like a real
deflection it seems to me because if you
look at the Bible the word Bibles never
mentioned once the term Christian has
never mentioned once the Trinity has
never mentioned once and I kind of feel
like all this modern day discussion
about Christianity and Jesus being God
is just because they're too empowered me
to actually focus on what is the amount
of sin that is going on so instead of
having
um balls about you in essence they go
why is our entire Financial system based
on usury and Reebok if you don't have
the courage to take that on you can just
create a problem out of nothing
and and certainly debate it until the
end days I have no time for it that
pushed me away from Christianity big
time because there doesn't seem to be
any proactivity whether it was just
debating dumb theology which made no
sense to me at all and then um you know
you read the Quran and how
how um
how do I wear this how straightforward
everything is you know I proactive
that was a breath of fresh air because
for a while I was trying to learn about
you know how to live You Know chords of
you know codes of
ethics a moral conduct and all I got was
are you drinking the blood and eating
the flesh or something yeah I mean it's
just I don't get it
yeah I think that's beautiful he said
bro I mean as the one of our subscribers
mentioned earlier God created us with
the Mind Christianity wants to take all
that away and just have us accept
whatever they claim frankly not what
makes sense to us and this whole issue
of them not wanting to be pragmatic and
practical and fix their society actually
comes from the creation of liberalism
because Christianity was the dominant
the church and the state were one that's
why they created secularism they
stripped the church away from the state
and said that we're not going to be
governed by the Bible or by you know
what people say God decreed or by God
we're just going to govern ourselves and
I mean look at look at where I got them
and that's why Christianity is what it
is today because it's been completely
divorced from law
I've never understood that when people
talk about separating Church in the
state as a bad thing I've never
understood that at all because if your
law is based on something that man made
then that law can be edited and changed
to suit whatever political agenda uh so
if you look at the age of consent for
example if your law isn't backed by a
strong faith why not change it to Japan
why not change it to 14. why not take
away the marriage aspect because if it's
made by man then man can I never
understood the idea that separating
church and state is a good idea and you
know what at the end of the day again
like you said you'll know them by other
fruits and their fruits are rotten at
the moment
um so yeah it's Christianity in my
opinion is
come back
he always cuts out with the best part
too I know he's about to rhyme active
man I'm waiting for it and then boom it
pauses
that's okay he was spitting up until up
until it rose again but we'll get him
back inshallah but I know you got to get
going soon so it's up to you if you want
to stay till he gets back to say Salam
or if you gotta go now oh it's okay wait
10 seconds come on bear bear
no
let him know I said salaam okay okay
always an honor having me on me
it's so funny he said it's always an
honor having me on
oh man
he's a funny guy all right here we go
figured out the problem I gotta figure
out what was going on can you hear me
yeah yeah we're back bro and then my
audio is gone one Earth is going on man
two seconds
right let me um rejoin quickly oh wait
hold on
let me leave and rejoin really quickly
all right take your time bro
all right
Trinity is nowhere to be found in the
Old Testament anyone who believes in it
is a heretic it's nowhere to be found in
the New Testament either bro what are
you talking about the only instance is
when uh I Think Jesus was getting
baptized or someone's getting baptized
and they said
um in the name of the father son Holy
Spirit but that doesn't describe what
the Trinity is that just names them
right
hmm
make a video with I'm listening to shot
love we will and shot love we will
that's a plan
so he's blaming the religion for the
issue of the nation uh those two aren't
conflated but no the problem is you
don't see a lot of Christians actually
pushing against this how many Christians
exist within you know
um America and Canada
and are they pushing back actually there
have been a lot of Christian communities
that have essentially there have been a
lot of Christian communities that
essentially have relapsed and and went
back on you know whatever they believe
and said you know we will let them do
whatever
but uh okay we got our brother back with
us welcome back thank you very much and
hopefully that's everything so hard now
I don't I don't know what's going on but
yeah um so yeah
I I try to not talk about
Christianity anymore because it's just
so infuriating to me it kind of it
really just annoys me how
nonchalant and uninterested they are in
actually removing the sin that's
currently in the world and it'll just
debate until the cows come home whether
Jesus was God so it's like so Jesus
um sent himself the impregnated Mary
with himself to give birth to himself to
then
um pass his kingdom back over to himself
to pray to himself to then go and sit at
the right hand right hand side of
himself and people will sit and talk
about that all day as kids are getting
exposed to porn on the internet and I go
what come on you know what I mean
it's just infuriating you know yeah it's
crazy yeah 100 I can I can definitely
it's beautiful because you're in the War
Room correct yeah yeah yeah it's
beautiful because I see this really
amazing pragmatic and practical
mentality from people who I've met who
are either friends with the tape
brothers or with the jewels shout out to
all them may Allah bless them inshallah
or they they are in the war room so I
want to ask about that and the influence
that maybe that had on your reversion to
Islam
so I've certainly got a lot of the um
more from just people who are because
I'm based in Scotland so the Muslim
population is quite low
um and I've got a lot of the whole oh
Andrew Tate did it so you're doing it
it's not nothing to do with that it's my
own determent that brought me to this
conclusion but um for example it was one
of the Warren brothers that took me for
my shahada
um and again like actually I say that
the population is low in Scotland but
the majority of the the War Room
Brothers in Scotland are Muslim and I
asked myself why why is that and it's
because they don't do Haram and they
replace Haram with
with working with getting things done
Etc so it's great I mean I've been
speaking to Jewel quite a lot he's
guided me through a lot of stuff and
it's very interesting actually because I
was just thinking earlier this time
uh a year and two months ago I was
working in a Potato Factory
and uh yesterday uh Joel sartorial
messaged me and I think it'll be fine
with me sharing this but he said that
uh Saudi not sodium Middle Eastern
Prince one of the billionaire guys had
sent Joel one of my videos
um and he's one of the guys that has no
Instagram like the big big dogs and I
just thought it's quite hilarious but
this is the thing when you start giving
up Haram everything that's said in the
Quran your life just starts to
exponentially Just Shoot To The Moon
because like you give up lost you know
have unlimited male energy you give up
music and replace it with information
you now have a sharper mind and a deeper
intellect than everyone around you so
it's interesting this is another reason
why I love Islam is because if my
trajectory continues going up Islam is
what keeps you grounded you know because
I I always I have the saying that
that shaitan's Temptations never go away
they just sort of change face so if
you're like a low status guy
and you struggle with lust you struggle
with um you know like different coping
mechanisms say you just scroll and Tick
Tock all day yeah say you're addicted to
pornography say that you are
um drinking all the time to deal with
your pain
if you become financially successful
those Temptations never go away the game
is still the same but they just change
face so you're um you know looking at
Instagram girls and pornography now
becomes a bunch of Haram and they want
to extract resources from you
through your own loss the substances go
from alcohol to
cocaine on a Billionaire's boat and
scrolling through Tech talk all day goes
from indulging in that to then indulging
in material things you've got and if you
started giving in to then all of your
success will slowly diminish over time
like so I'm very glad that I found it at
the stage because I feel like had I
have had I have had the outward
trajectory without Islam then there's
every chance that if I didn't have that
strong moral Foundation everything could
have crumbled around me because then you
know where do you draw the line with
certain things you could get uh on me
too case with this modern day feminism
all this stuff so I'm very glad that I
found it at my age you know I think it's
the greatest
bench mechanism against her you know
evil in the world also it's certainly a
blessing
absolutely I think that's that's
beautifully said uh someone commented
that you're 22 is that true
I wish I wish I knew this when I was a
teenager I feel like things would have
went a lot better
so yeah 21 22 and uh
a few months so again like I said it's
such a blessing because I found it in
this age you know because you look at
what can happen to men nowadays yeah
like with the whole divorce thing like a
guy can work his whole life
because he was too blinded by his own
lust we lose half his stuff substance
abuse Etc so to find it at this age it
really has been
a real blessing and thanks to
Christianity for being so cocked as well
because if they weren't I would never
offend Islam you know so I guess the
Trinity has its positives you know what
I mean yeah
alhamdulillah I mean Allah he says in
the Quran that the truth has come and
falsehood has vanished indeed falsehood
is bound to vanish because and it's like
it's like turning on light in a dark
room it's like you know you can see you
know any any of the Shadows you thought
you saw in the dark or anything that you
thought you know moved you don't know
what it is any confusion you had just
boom you know exactly what's going on as
soon as the lights turned on right so
that's why the light of Allah the the
Noor of Allah is something that is
profound and we ask Allah to keep us
guided Allah I mean but the stuff you
were sharing actually is very Advanced I
think it's very profound and that's why
I mentioned the war room because I see
this like I mentioned mentality with
Jewel again shout out to the brother and
with you and people you know who are
like-minded to them where they just seem
to understand life better than you know
a lot of other people even born Muslims
and that's something I mentioned to
Jewel when I first met him that the way
he understands Islam is just so much
better than even born Muslims because
they remove this beautiful practical
aspect of it you know the whole thing
about it protects you from evils and
shaytan switching face I love how you
said that bro because it's absolutely
true you know shaytan will even use your
own religion against you he will even
try and twist your religion to get you
to commit something that's that's that's
evil in a sense right he'll play with
your intentions for example let's say
you know how you may have to make will
do it before you go pray he will he will
he will do something along the lines of
making you try and perfect it so much
that you think you need to keep redoing
your will do over and over because you
just can't get it right it's not perfect
enough and then it gets to a point where
you delay your Salah so much you delay
your prayer so much he'll try and make
you
either over complicate over explain
overdo or whatever with the religion and
it might actually cause harm to yourself
or other people so shaytan is a very
tricky person he's been doing this for
thousands of years so he's has a lot of
experience over us but we have the Quran
over him and the guidance from Allah
yeah 100 it's interesting you mentioned
how um
a lot of people who have reverted to
Islam seem to be quite well versed in
what's going on and I kind of feel like
people like me like Jill like Andrew
Tate for an example as well I kind of
feel like you know if you have this is
uh something that I read in the Quran it
was um I can't remember the specifics
but it was when the Mongolian Empire
took over the Islamic empire and it was
said that one Mongolian woman could walk
into a house of 50 Muslim men and kill
them all because it becomes so rich and
sedated
and I kind of feel like with I think
you'll notice this as well there's a lot
of new Scholars who are trying to kind
of water down Islam I think there's
going to be some infiltration shortly
where they try and tell women all the
hijabs not necessary or if you wanted
because I Know Reba I've been speaking
to quite a lot of people because now
everyone I talk to is Muslim that Reba's
been normalized to her degree and I feel
like me and Joel and people like that
we're kind we're kind of people who were
in the wilderness and we can see an army
charging towards the Fortress and we're
running over going you have to stay
strong you know because we've had our
boots on the ground in the west and
seeing how disgusting it gets like the
amount of heartache and a break
and I feel like
you know hard times create strong men
and me and Joel Etc
experiencing what this modern day
hedonistic atheist
nihilistic do as though well world what
the fruits of that rotten tree and how
poisonous they are yeah I feel like
we're kind of like Messengers that will
ensure that Islam doesn't get water done
because we've seen how bad it gets when
you when you
when you water down your Dean you know
when you start to be complacent with
things how horrific it gets like it's so
crazy
um
like like out in the west the amount of
degeneracy and like the average life for
like a young guy now is he's molested on
his phone from nine years old till 20 he
gets into debt he's lied to his whole
life a young woman if she's not if she's
not lost her virginity after coming up
to high school she's ashamed so we have
these broken people who are all in debt
all afraid have no skills and then you
get these new
um because I think it's very clear now
that Islam is the the final Hope For
Humanity and I think the people who are
trying to hurt the sheep for example
and uh control the world they're now
going to start to try and infiltrate
Islam and I think that people like me
and Joel our messages to go you have to
stay strong because any compromise like
where do you draw the line if you start
compromising on like women wearing the
hijab Etc how do you then stop them from
posting Haram things on Instagram and
then just where that leads to because
we've had our boots on the ground
you know you have to say strong and it's
hard nowadays because of the amount of
Temptation
um but yeah it stays strong with the
team because it gets really bad man like
really bad out here so yeah 100 and
people need to be really careful about
where they get even their Islamic
Knowledge from because like you
mentioned and by the way this is already
taken form this has been in the works
for like Years bro I'd say maybe even
two decades like 20 long years since you
know the that event that happened with
the Twin Towers I'm not going to say
because
since then since then they've been
planning very meticulously how to
undermine Islam there have been you know
reports written by Rand and other
governmental agencies who have this
specific task of trying to undermine
Islam and make it more democratic make
it more liberal make it less Sharia like
and they have done this in the form of
paying institutions paying imams
delegating exactly what is and isn't and
can and can't be said about Islam and
there are many aspects of our religion
that a lot of Muslims
unfortunately watered down a lot of well
will water down and there's a Hadith the
prophet peace be upon him where he said
there will come a time where people from
my nation Muslims look to make alcohol
men wearing silk
adultery fornication and and music Halal
they try and make these four things
craziness I I wish I could talk about
that event because that really
interferiates me but I will because I
I've been striked two times on YouTube
so I know a sense of who they are gonna
Rumble man
yeah I I don't remember but if I could
say one thing for the listeners that
won't let you banned regarding that
event I look up the seventh the seventh
building that went down and have it just
suicide did itself it's so garbage like
this is the problem like you were saying
with them
paying institutions this is one thing
that Sharia law would outlaw because you
can't have fiat currency and I say this
all this is what actually what kind of
got me banished to a degree I actually
think it was because I mentioned the
yeah
um but if you have fiat currency and
it's not backed by a hard asset like
gold or silver like it would be in a
Shalia you can just print as much money
as you need to pay people to do things
so if you want to infiltrate Islam you
can just print with the Federal Reserve
10 billion bucks there's no one stopping
you give it to these people give them
enough until they accept the Haram like
has to go I'm So Pro Sharia law man like
I'm so crucial yeah I've been looking
into it like you said regarding
fornication and adultery a lot of people
will sit there and say oh because I
think the the punishment for adultery in
Sharia is um I don't want to get you
banned but it's like yeah and it's like
if you start allowing adultery what
happens the family unit breaks what
happens to the kids you look at
statistics of young guys that grow up
without a dad the crime rate goes
through the roof okay so that's going to
lead to more murders going to lead to
more crimes more drug abuse more debt
the women will become promiscuous
because they've lost faith in the idea
of marriage and love so when people have
a problem with having a law that's
actually enforced
think logically you know and I think
people are too blinded by their sin and
that's why they won't accept things like
Sharia because that that solves every
single problem in the world though like
it's crazy
um yeah so yeah like that's the thing
like as long as fiat currency exists
you're going to struggle to stop this
and I say this all the time with things
like Tick Tock things like Instagram
things like the pornography industry
they're all free and as everything in
the world is shooting through the roof
as the cost of living and the cost of
everything is going through the roof why
do these things like music why is cardi
B's music always still free well if
these things lose money every year
because if you look at I think 35 of all
internet traffic is pornography right
which if you wanted to like
back in the day it was hard now every
single kid gets almost is because of
what's in their pocket that industry
does not make money it's all free the
way they keep it afloat is if you have
fiat currency you can print as much
money as you need they don't care about
profits they make the money you can
print as much as you need give it to
that industry so they say a float is
crazy to me
um but yeah like you said the amount of
propaganda with events like the the 120
years ago and that's why people are
afraid of things like it's crazy but the
idea like we said with the adultery
thing
um
how that is a very punishable act and it
should be people don't see that as
liberating and they've been so
brainwashed that now the idea of a woman
wearing a hijab and not being seen as
like this before Europe or weak men's
loss apparently that's
um what's the word like misogynist and
not empowering but only fans is now the
fourth biggest career choice in the West
for a woman so selling yourself online a
man who don't care about you for fake
money is backed by nothing more than
bombs that's empowering people are too
blinded by their sin and what do the
Christians do when this is going on oh
Jesus was God he prayed to himself as I
just burn it down in my eyes crazy you
know and Furious yeah 100 and it's
unfortunate because like people will
hear you say sharing a lot and they'll
just lose their mind because they don't
know what it is right because it's so
it's so demonized in the west but let me
explain it's just some parts of sharia
law
do you want to not ever pay income tax
again
yeah do you want do you want a system
that is based on like things that
actually have tangible value you know
Commodities like gold and silver and
diamonds and jewels and do you want that
kind of system or do you want a system
that's based on money that will that
will inflate over time that's you know
no more valuable and it's physical
attributes and this piece of paper I'm
holding here
and that if you know the the the the
reserve currency switches which it might
happen soon would cause a complete
decimation and destruction economically
of a country if you want that go to
liberalism capitalism these Western
societies if you want something
commodity based that's what Allah is if
you want medical care for you free of
charge
that's not going to be something you
find in in America these beautiful
things are done by Sharia because the
job of the Khalifa unlike the president
the job of the Khalifa is to instill the
best interests of their people the
processarily said that the the the
leader is The Shepherd of those under
him those following him and that the
relationship between the Khalifa the
Islamic ruler and the the community is
one where he is taking care of them he
loves them they love him so on and so
forth
yeah I totally get what you mean the
thing with taxes as well like people are
so brainwashed man it's like you don't
need taxes so people will talk about how
like oh someone making a 100K a year and
to be taxed 50 percent
they'll tax you and then go print 10
trillion to go bomb a country oversea
they don't need your tax money think
with your head you know I mean and for
the people who are non-muslim I believe
and I could be wrong so um
I'm pretty sure that the tax for a
non-muslim in a Sharia Society is like
2.5
would you prefer that less than that it
might actually probably less I think it
might be so it's like would you like
that or would you like your 60 in Canada
when you make more than 100K a year
which doesn't even buy you a house it's
just ridiculously like this is what
happens and this is the thing with them
the taxes in my opinion is they don't
need it but the reason you're taxed so
heavily is because when they get you
into debt with fear
you have to show up to work you have to
comply with things like the
um c19 thing
because if you don't you lose your job
you lose your house Etc
so if they can tax you 50 as well they
then prolong the debt period where you
can't stand up to anything because you
don't actually own the assets that
you're using because of usury and reboot
um it's an interesting one man I'm not
I'm not sure because I
this way of living in the West where it
can't go on because the birth rate is so
low every young guy nowadays is so
incapable of doing anything because of
all the brainwashing the US Dollars
collapsing into nothing and I'm pretty
sure on the Swift system nations are
coming away from it so it's like what
if you don't want Sharia to replace that
you can get a Stalin who will come in
and give you communism he'll wipe out
your migration he'll wipe out your fiat
currency you'll wipe out your
um your duvets and your nightclubs but
you're not going to get along to that
and you know it's like these things
can't go on forever it'll be very
interesting to see what replaces that
system because the like like in the I
don't know the Quran says but I know the
Bible does where it says rotten
Royal and trees bear rotten fruits and
you know a rotten tree can't very good
fruits so the system is destined to
collapse so it'll be interesting to see
what replaces it I mean and this may be
overly ambitious in some people's eyes
but you know being where I am at 21 with
the information I have the resources I
have one of the Ambitions I have would
be to try and bring in Sharia to the
West you know because I've had enough of
it I'm not going to bring in because I
want to have loads of kids I'm not
having sons and daughters but by the
time they're nine years old they're
exposed to the most disgusting things on
the internet imaginable and you can't
escape it it's crazy it's ridiculous um
so you know anything like that can
happen but it's a weird time and it's
crazy to me as well it seems like people
want to be enslaved because of YouTube
an hour of your day just to read over
Sharia and what it is it's so clear as
day that it is like a Divine source of
law but people won't do that and it's
crazy to me I don't I don't understand
that I don't relate to it but you know
inshallah it will be Sharia that
replaces instead of this
Central Bank digital without getting
striked I don't think so the the new
currency you know
it's a weird time man it's very
interesting yeah yeah yeah inshallah
inshallah one thing we know for sure is
that Islam will Triumph everything
eventually eventually we know actually I
think it might get a little bit worse
before it gets better but Islam is going
to to come clutch in the end and the
reason is because it is something that
Allah has promised right God himself has
promised that stone will come back and
not just because we believe it but
because it's a it's a system that is
built to dominate look at what the
prophet saws did the best example is
that of the Prophet peace upon him his
companions he came in a tribalistic
society it's a completely different
ideology they were tribes they actually
hated each other they wanted to murder
each other and the prophet salaam he
came he taught this message he meant
persecution in the form of name-calling
slander against his name boycotts
economic sanctions even many other
things all of which they do today by the
way to people you know they tried to
offer the prophet saws to be a king for
them he's like oh just come be a king
for us just stop preaching this and slam
stuff why because they wanted to
continue with their way they wanted to
continue to have people pay to worship
idols they wanted to continue taking
advantage of the poor in the week they
want to continue to take people and put
them into you know slavery under their
own authority without any actual
authoritative accountability over them
the process of them rejected that
obviously and then eventually Islam
dominated and he built his sahaba a
whole group of people that eventually
beat quresh they beat Mecca they
dominated became the rulers of Mecca
they were the rulers of Medina and
eventually within you know a few decades
they conquered Rome Persia what was left
of Persia up to the borders of China and
Islam expanded not in the way that
Christianity did which actually by the
way a lot of times with Constantine was
by force and coercion Islam expanded for
the most part just by things like trade
and by people accepting it on their own
accord because it made the most sense
and is something that lasted for a
thousand years capitalism and liberalism
definitely cannot do that it is not
sustainable
yeah if you look at the expansion of the
Islamic empire you can thank Sharia law
finances for that I find it funny as
well like how do I say this
I think I think there's going to be more
false Idols that revert to Islam to then
subvert it and I'm not going to name
names but I can see that they will try
to do that so for example like you said
they're the prophet Muhammad peace be
upon him he was throwing all these
things again trying to trying to get him
to just talk and yes I can't think of a
better word to say and I kind of feel
like there's going to be a few people if
not already that are going to Revere and
they're going to become idols and then
the the the young population of Muslims
will no longer be interested in
sacrificing their material possessions
for what is actually right so
um
to a degree actually so yeah I think
that's going to happen there's going to
be a lot of infiltration from false
Idols
um I've completely lost my train of
thought I was going on uh and I can't
remember what I was going to say my
apologies no worries were you were you
going to say that a lot of these people
who start to worship false Idols as
Muslims are going to start preaching
that to the people and try and confuse
people who look into Islam yes I think
yes exactly I think that there's so the
people in control of the world they
can't do anything to you and I say when
people talk about the Matrix and I made
a video on this the other day that when
people come to you and they tell you you
need a Lamborghini or your wife's going
to leave you you need to be this and
that and that that's just marketing it's
creating a problem where there is none
so they can sell you the solution
and what I think is going to happen is
they're going to bring in Idols if
they've not already who are hyper
materialistic or sterile but the young
males look up to them so they're going
to be like oh you need to get your
Lamborghini or you're a loser you need
to have this much money or you're a
loser you need to get with all these
girls or you're a loser and because
there's a lack of masculine Role Models
the young Muslim population are going to
idolize these people but the actual it's
like when Farmers give their cattle feed
so they can milk them they'll give you
your nice Idol and you'll go oh finally
there's a masculine role model all I
need now is a Ferrari and a bunch of
Haram women
and I think they're going to bring in
these people so that those young young
Muslims who would actually stand up and
start you know having marriages and and
getting out of debt and speaking the
truth and will become too afraid to
speak the truth because they've been
marketed too heavily that they need
their Ferrari they need these this cool
Instagram account all this stuff so I
would watch out for the false Idols
particularly because especially in the
influence her age I think that's the way
they're going to Target people I mean if
they're up to me speaking of influencers
I would but I would just burn Instagram
to the ground I'd burn Twitter to the
ground I'd burn all I'm actually
building my own social media for this
thing
um just because of how much propaganda
can be spread on these platforms the
amount of idol worship that can go on
again I always talk about the
the Lost side of things and what a child
can see unwillingly
so yeah watch out for the false prophets
because I I I'm pretty sure they're
gonna start pumping them into Islamic
the young males and make them sterile
and materialistic Etc so I would watch
out for that 100 because then those guys
who put things like money on a pedestal
put things like followers on a pedestal
if someone goes to
um
and someone wants to cancel these things
take away their money and take away
their platform
they're not going to denounce that and
stick to their deal like the prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him did because
they've put material possessions on such
a pedestal so I would certainly watch
out for that again if it's not already
occurred I'm not gonna say anything
because I don't want to get like should
I say you did or not you know
yeah so where where can they find more
of you on this topic unfiltered
um unfill there's a hard one so I'm I am
making my own social media called
diagram which I think is a cool name so
on there because I will own the servers
I can say what I want but on YouTube I
can get my message across in a way
without saying trigger words so my my
YouTube is Lord Bear logos or Lord bear
if you just type that and I'll be the
first one that comes up
um very valuable content I didn't follow
it because there's a good chance I could
get banned any minute I've had two
strikes and oh this is another thing
regarding just before I go yeah and we
were talking about how they're going to
get these people to start watering down
Islam I had my channel for two weeks I
got strikes twice if you see people with
massive platforms
who are preaching the same thing just
question as to why that could be because
if they want you banned you will be
banned so if you see people with massive
performance who are saying well actually
in this uh Hadith says that
um only fans is great you know like just
be careful because these people are on
these platforms there's a reason that
they're allowed on it so so yeah you can
find me on on YouTube would be the
majority
um a place to go and then from there all
my other stuff I'll look out for diagram
because it's going to sync Instagram and
Twitter into the ground because I've had
enough of them
inshallah my brother may Allah
I mean you heard it here first guys
Charlotte go check them out subscribe
and if he loses his account you could
probably find him on Rumble and the new
social media platform that he's creating
inshallah which may Allah Graham success
in that uh look forward to having you
again on soon bro I think you got a lot
a lot of good to share and inshallah
we'll do this again soon my brother
Michael
all right alhamdulillah amazing brother
amazing talk you guys want to continue
with the um reaction to brother roslan
on sneakers reversion also to the person
that said that capitalism and Islam are
not like you know opposing in any way
that is the most ignorant thing I've
heard I'm sorry pure what is pure
capitalism pure capitalism
at its core is that one percent of
people
profit off of as much as possible and
everybody else suffers that every ounce
of society is made private and there's
not one thing that's public you know so
imagine police fire health care every
single thing is private
there's not a there's not a public
sector in existence
and what will happen is a very few small
percent of people would profit greatly
and own like everything and then
everyone else will suffer obviously no
one's going to accept that the numbers
the masses will not accept that so they
had to make it social friendly so they
made a social presently
but capitalism Islam are two completely
different things for example he said
that there are a few things that every
everyone in humanity are co-owners in he
said the pastures the fires the wells
and water and so on and so forth all
these things are free to people
you can also derive things like you know
health care and all that stuff
so Islam 100 goes against the capitalism
it goes against socialism as well
and the problem with these ideologies is
that they're man-made and men are not
perfect which means they will make
flawed laws and you might say what's the
problem with that you know what happens
when a law is flawed you know how many
people suffer this by the way is one of
the reasons that is the worst sin
a big reason if not the reason is the
worst sin in existence
is because it causes people to make
their own laws their own way of life and
then put that way of life upon the
masses of people that are under them and
they automatically always take advantage
of the poor take advantage of the weak
take advantage of those who cannot help
themselves or speak up for themselves
and they do not equalize them in any way
and they will always take whatever they
can from the system they created that's
the problem with man-made ideology
that's the problem with shirk
worshiping Allah
is calling on none other than him not
doing any good acts except for him and
fully obeying nobody except him
if you don't do these three things you
can't say you worship Allah if you
negate to neglect any of these three
things you are committing
and that's why Islam is powerful
because it's not only clear and concise
and makes sense
but it's practical it's pragmatic and a
lot of the good that we have even in
Western societies came from Islam let me
go on a rant a little bit
Child Benefits the amount of money you
get from the government because you have
a baby came from um
who was the second
caliph of Islam after Abu Bakr
um or the third after the processary if
you consider him the first
that came from um
the basic fundamental method which is a
scientific method came from ibincina
from the Muslim world who even seen some
say that he fell out of the fall of
Islam with some of his beliefs but his
his uh practice everything came from the
Islamic Society he lived in the Golden
Age of Islam same thing with IBN and
haitham same thing with algorithms
same thing with
um with with laws for example innocent
are proven guilty
was made really mainstream by the
Muslims and there is historian who wrote
about this and how this Muslim way got
introduced to Western society and just
in case you don't believe me during the
translational era or era for Europe they
were translating a bunch of Arabic books
of philosophy and law in mathematics and
science and religion and all these
things from Arabic to Latin right from
Arabic to Latin and then they studied
these things and then made it the basis
of their basically you know their their
revolutions
and they benefited based off what the
Muslims did
and now
with their man-made ideology and their
laws which that caused the the
oppression of women the oppression of
different uh cultures the oppression of
different people all these problems
children being abused all these horrible
things that their laws got them they
think that now they can reprimand all
that and then say look at all these
problems and throw it on to Islam
oh look at how women aren't free the
reason you don't think women are free is
because you oppress them for for years
you oppress them for decades and now all
of a sudden just because she wears a
Buddha she's not free when you're the
one who oppressed her for for a long
time you're the one who didn't give her
the right to vote Islam gave that 1400
years ago why are you coming to us
saying oh you're forced them to work in
a club
get the heck out of here what the heck
do you know
you just recently discovered that
yourself boy
I pulled out the boy like Muhammad hijab
Islam just makes sense it's
understandable only to people who use
their mind I mean honestly if we're
being real the only people who will not
accept Islam are those who are arrogant
those who are vastly ignorant or those
who presuppose that something else is
true like liberalism a lot of people
just presuppose liberalism is true and
good but you live in the Society of
course you're going to think that
so I think that's that's one of the
biggest problems and they set a standard
for religion and for God that they don't
set for anything else
and I don't just mean in the sense that
you know extraordinary claims require
extraordinary evidence we provide
extraordinary evidence like like
prophecies which can only be proven in
hindsight
they don't want to accept that
so may Allah make it easy for us
may Allah guide all of those
who have not been guided may Allah keep
us on the straight path I mean at all
I guess I'll get back to the um the
reaction here inshallah
these are Jesus is even whatever
position you take yeah yeah
he's not no one ever literally ate
Jesus's flesh and drank his actual blood
yeah the blood that was shed on the
cross and in that I I comment
Romney addressed Faith flicks they keep
saying the Bible mentioned in the Quran
is what the Christians use today
um firstly the Quran does not say the
Bible says the gospel and you don't have
the gospel you have the Gospel According
to Mark Matthew Luke John they'll all
differ in different ways and focus on
completely different things and then you
have the rest of it which is the New
Testament written by people like Paul
and Luke who never met Jesus and other
people who claim to be Peter but it was
a forgery he wasn't actually Peter he
lied and then second Peters was the same
thing so
please you know just educate yourself on
this first and foremost and just don't
believe me look into it for yourself
you'll see
do wish that someone
could have given him a different picture
of this in a different example because
this is
of the sacrament there are certain folks
that the bread and the wine is is is a
meal yeah right it's it's a meal you
have like a dinner Feast yeah and that's
beautiful how beautiful is the bread and
the wine right the the wine is actually
is actually viewed throughout history as
the drink of the rich yeah and the bread
the food of the poor and so the
beautiful thing about about
um
the Eucharist that sometimes people
don't talk about is that this is where
the poor and the rich come together
interesting you know what I'm saying at
the table to receive uh to be a family
you know what I mean and for me this is
just beautiful imagery yeah all right so
let's go back so that's the first thing
I I noticed and I was like man that's
really interesting because I instantly
thought of that that Bible passage but I
was I was also genuinely curious like
how deep did he go on this right just
because something sounds a certain way
you're not factoring in figurative
language you're not factoring in any
anything you know there's it's just yeah
it sounds like a shallow rebuttal to
something that was addressed in
scripture or not not enough homework I
wasn't addressed in Scripture it wasn't
at all it's just he just mentioned
generally that um multiple times you
know this is the this is the bread and
this is the wine and this is the Flesh
and this is the blood and if you eat it
then you will have eternal life he just
says that like seven times he doesn't
actually explain what it means um and
the problem again is not that it exists
in Christian uh scripture the problem is
that people practice it at Mass they
drink wine at Mass they eat bread at
Mass I remember I was so ignorant as a
kid I went to a Catholic school and I
always tried to skip Wednesdays because
that's when they had mass and I didn't
want to go because on top of not being a
Christian it was just long and boring so
the first time I was there I didn't know
what the heck was going on everyone
stood up gotten a line started walking
to the front I'm like okay I'm doing
this and then they give me uh they give
me the the little uh Sacrament or
whatever and I just see everyone eating
it I'm like
okay
that was it
and it's like what is the point of that
I don't see the point of that and to
back it up with scripture you have to
have some kind of evidence for it did
the disciples practice this does Jesus
practice this
seems like in the Gospel of John he just
said it seven times
work right or not enough homework but
this is the thing that attracts uh a lot
of people a lot of um people who grew up
Christian to
Islam Islam has more sex sectors of
Islam that are very very
um of
overtly fundamental you know what I mean
interviews where they know that they
know that they know sure right and so
when when that is advertised to a
Christian it's like you ever had any
issues with the Trinity yeah well we
don't because we don't believe in it
right you haven't had any issues with
you know yeah and even in the verse in
the previous verse where Jesus talks
about like human effort doesn't mean
anything like you don't earn your way to
heaven I don't understand this point I
really don't get it we have different
factions that are all very certain about
what they believe I don't understand
that like in 95 to 99 of Muslims in the
world are are Sunni so I don't I don't
really don't understand what he's what
he's saying there and that contradicts
the innate nature in people to want to
earn their righteousness right right you
want it doesn't make sense to say you
buy grace through faith you're saved you
have this natural propensity to want to
perform and and do good things
absolutely not every not every Act of
obedience
comes in knowing everything sometimes it
comes out of knowing who God is and
saying hey I'm just going to trust the
Lord because you're eating his body his
body's a symbol of the cracker that's
true and then he drank the wine that's a
symbol of his blood this is Jesus blood
and you sip it out of respect for it for
him and I I like the fact that Islam it
doesn't draw Muhammad peace we bought
him you're not supposed to ever
visualize that because we have he was
not alive in our time there's no way
that we would know what he looked like
especially Allah God he's never drawn we
have no idea what he looks like or
because there's no way humans are too
stupid we would never we're not mentally
capable of understanding what God we
can't conceptualize conceptually so it's
not supposed to in Christianity or grow
up and you have like God on a cloud and
it's like this guy with a white dude on
a beard he's like laying in a cloud and
he's like putting his hand down so it's
interesting that he has an issue with
Christian iconography
yeah I don't know what to make of that
obviously there's certain Christian
imagery that's not helpful for example
blonde hair blue-eyed white jesus
absolutely not helpful not helpful at
all
um but then there's other stuff that's
beautiful and amazing the the Sistine
Chapel in Rome I'm not I'm not a
Catholic but I've been there it's
incredible yeah there's a lot of
Christian art and sculpture and
Innovation and music and hymns and
gospel music that's amazing so he goes
to specifically like we can't
conceptualize God but I'm like yeah I
don't that's not the same as having an
idol of someone drawings paintings right
not exactly the same thing I'm sorry
Ruslan that's exactly the same thing we
have painting of what Jesus allegedly
looked like you are idolizing someone
who you believe is God I I don't think
it's that confusing to be honest I think
the video is pretty long so I'm not
gonna go through the whole thing but
I mean like it's pretty it's pretty
clear here
you're drawing a picture of a man who
you believe was God the house idolizing
God or making him to an image or an idol
I I really don't understand that and by
the way to the person to mentioned that
Jesus did uh kind of mention the the
bread and wine or the last supper I
don't mean is it in in the New Testament
I mean did Jesus actually say that did
you actually say these things we believe
in the uh the the table spread that was
sent down to Jesus and his disciples but
that actual phrasing did he say that
there was a book written by the Jesus
seminar and some some other Scholars
called the five Gospels
I mentioned this a lot and they rated
every saying of Jesus they put in in
bold black letters anything that he did
and he definitely never said they put in
Gray letters because he probably didn't
say they put in pink letters things that
okay it's he probably said it or it's
reasonable to think he said it and they
put in Red Letters things he really
likely said most of the book majority of
the book is just like black letters
which means most of the things that are
in the New Testament they believe that
Jesus just never said to begin with and
there's reason to believe that like I
mentioned I have the podcast coming out
with Dr Dennis McDonald who authored uh
honestly an encyclopedia talking about
how a lot of stories about Jesus were
stolen from previous figures and put
onto Jesus and it was actually a
practice they had called literary well
what he called literary nemesis
it's actually it's honestly it's like an
art it's really beautiful the way they
do it it's just these things never
actually happen to Jesus Jesus never
actually did these things
it happens a lot and inshallah when the
when the episode comes out you guys can
look into that but I think I'm gonna go
ahead and end off this episode soon
Insha'Allah and would love to hear from
you guys and take some comments here
the problem the problem why they can't
understand Islam is because they can't
be humble they think God came to them
wrong you have to go to God I think
that's a I think that's a good point but
the thing is when you when you take a
step towards Allah Allah will come to
you many for the law will make it easier
you know we have the Hadith whoever you
know uh basically goes out a hand
stretched to Allah Allah will go out
like an Armstrong to him and so on and
so forth
the most illogical thing about their
arguments is that every religion could
use them and could use against them yeah
like the whole thing about faith you
know just have faith okay well I just
have faith in Islam and that's it
actually I don't just have faith it's
based on evidence but I'm going to use
the argument for for them
Adrian much love brother may Allah bless
you inshallah
um please guess nickel on more he needs
a better form than his ideas on Islam he
deported on freshman but he just
accepted his number relax he literally
just accepted his thumb I'm pretty sure
if you just started studying something
you wouldn't articulate yourself in the
best manner either and by the way sneak
was actually doing an amazing job the
way he was speaking with Gideon was
shout out to jidion and a few other
people I actually think he did a great
job of it I believe he said some things
maybe that were that weren't exactly
correct and may Allah you know guide him
but you know we're going to work with
them a lot inshaallah in the future and
in future episodes and stuff and I think
you've been doing a great job recently
the three most important to Romney's
Channel now I have my own channel Rami
and khadil look it up inshallah you'll
see a dashing picture of myself as the
profile picture but no inshallah the
brothers are going to be back soon
they're just both super busy and super
hard working
sneakers doing really well considering
how many Christians are dog piling him
yeah 100 and you know this is important
Muslims need to support snico especially
with the way you've been representing
Islam bro I honestly he's been doing an
amazing job and we as Muslims need to
support him against anyone who's trying
to go at him anyone's trying to call him
insulting names we need to go against
him anyone who's trying to say he just
accepted it for clout we need to go
against him anyone who's saying here
he's just following Andrew Tate we need
to go against them
as his brother he is our beloved uh our
beloved brother in Islam our you know
brother in belief
also the gospel is against Muslim
theology you have to deny God's word no
actually new testament Scholars not
Muslims they're not Muslim none of them
New Testament Scholars said this people
who studied Greek and Aramaic and Hebrew
those who actually looked at the
evidences those who are taught and
learned in uh textual criticism they
said that not me the Quran does say that
yes and it's also proven empirically
please explain difference of teaching
dawah such as
versus
that's a hefty question man
um
I don't want to name names so I'm going
to remove all those names from your head
remove all those names from your head I
think people need different forms of
doubt I think there's a software
approach and for people who are softer
you know like the young men and women I
think they need soft approach from for
for for some guys who are really kind of
hot-headed and they need to be yelled at
to get the point across to them they'll
appreciate you know someone like Mohamed
hablos for that
may Allah bless them I think he gives
amazing lectures I think there's also an
aspect that people unfortunately who do
water down the religion unnecessarily
um and although some people might
disagree with um whether that's okay or
not I think it's absolutely abhorrent
and wrong to water down Islam Islam is
as Allah revealed it and something my
teacher taught me recently is it's not
up to us to choose when someone's ready
to hear something or not it's not up to
us to choose when to give a revelation
of Allah since he already sent it down
so yeah we have to be wise if they will
accept it better tomorrow than today
okay maybe there's room for that but we
have to be straight up about our
religion and not lie and who are we
lying for honestly like what
who are we lying for
there are secular Scholars that deny
every religion yeah but their field is
in biblical studies their field is in
the New Testament that's what they're
studied and learned in
you don't have by the way people who
study the Quran saying the same thing
actual Scholars who studied Islamic
history saying the same thing you don't
they would they wouldn't dare deny it
because there's no evidence that says
the Quran has been changed like the
evidence that shows the Bible definitely
has been
um I brought this up by accident Rami
can you be Christian without believing
the Trinity address that for Jalen
Jackson since he doesn't want to answer
me
um uh it depends on what on what
denomination you are like you can't be a
Catholic and not believe in the training
because you're not Catholic anymore but
there are some denominations of of
Christianity that um
don't believe the Trinity I wonder why
shark is unforgivable sin it's too
confusing just keep it simple one God I
discussed before the dangers of sugar
earlier if you want to go back and see
Rami bro American Voice is asking you if
you can come on he's a river also oh
reacts um
any of those Brothers want to come on
send me uh Instagram DM not the three
Muslims DM but my personal DM ramir
khanil inshallah I'll be happy to bring
you on maybe for a brief second or we
can schedule something next week
so uh make sure you hit me up inshallah
but I do think I'm going to go ahead and
end it off soon
a smart Muslim Scholars yes yes he's
very um very well known very popular
I wouldn't say harshness with others as
a process of some tradition we should be
grateful for our diversities and days
yeah sorry ignore the train if you can
hear that in the back I'm gonna move for
a second
we're back
um if nowadays Paul writes to his
friends Christians will make what's up
his what's up is God's words that's
funny the reason it's funny is because
he wrote letters and um those letters
basically went um
or widespread and people kind of took it
as you know prophetic tradition I guess
you could say
the high priests are too busy being okay
thanks
there are many smart Muslim Scholars the
one does not again whenever he said one
that gets the other don't worry we're
not we're not like hating on Imam and
bukhari because we praise them Allah
don't worry we're good inshallah
but uh type I think that's enough for
one day I would love to talk to Roseland
doesn't look like it's gonna happen in
person but if he's down shall I'd love
to do it uh even in this format online
um amazing guest today brother Jad and
brother bear my Loveless and both
immensely inshallah I think I'm gonna go
ahead and end it off with that being
said
I'll see you guys